hello welcome to this video playing
Kevin king Tom Spain probably yeah I
need something else and the sameish hit
sister and you get that line all of the
time people see don't seem to know that
this is back okay so let's go 85 if you
don't want to fight for the center i'm
happily taking it okay queenie for mmm
the question is is 95 a move or not is
there some trick with Queen traps that
sometimes works 95 King's I have a hard
time to believe it and if he really
plays that I still have Queen g4 I mean
not see 528 there should be seven green
eggs SL every three that should work it
really shouldn't work
I want to play if he play c6 I play
Bishop d3 g6 bishops it was something
like that even though you can actually
argue that yeah he tries he tries this
move I mean if he does not play it his
position is totally totally rotten so I
understand and understand the point but
I don't believe it really works let's
see takes Bishop d7 Queen takes a 7 that
shouldn't work he might have this check
maybe it just plays for that but it's a
full look so let's see ya when that term
I don't believe at all I can go back to
a 3 ok so i take this and your
alternative no i don't think so i think
i have to check and now Bishop e3
there should be three anyway to get
castling and even quicker queen bee to
maybe look the 822 should work
22 can go Quincy form 23 edits all still
continuous this game b-52 maybe
I might castle long that's one idea of
52 I think I can so long here I Scott
Bishop before as well why it's getting
really annoying this stuff but at least
I'm I'm threatening things now myself
Bishop Bishop move this is a threat
amazing i'm tricky the still was maybe I
did I do something wrong with the start
of this line somehow I mean I don't know
sometimes you just annoyed like that it
is that the game is just going on and on
and on when you are basically I look up
but maybe it was it was just what it is
he has some some kind of tricks up his
sleeve they have to play a couple of
good defensive moves damp no I think I
should should have things reasonably
well under control
still continues I mean it's six that's
not great they have to watch for c5
don't want to run into some stupid for
cam time warning let's return some stuff
here
we can take your rent check check check
okay well when they pawn but it's a it's
a piece check 30 seconds check check
25 check
check check check check no more four
seconds check check check check late Oh
Ed's got amazingly tricky after being a
look up after move 11 so let's check
this Jan 356 Teague's yeah ok there's
also 95 maybe that's also good this is
what the computer is giving g 6 h-4 and
so it's a very brutal age 5 s is are is
a big threat this is the computers line
typically typically we had computer done
this is this and then he cannot save the
rook here I'd be seven and I'm winning
an exchange for a pawn okay well i
played this and well this shouldn't work
but it got the eight code tricky I'd
really got tricky check so I have to
take maybe we should be three nows what
the computer is giving but it shouldn't
be too bad now Bishop g5 is probably
better
yeah this is better 27 and then 22 was
working that's very very clear out ok so
that was better than Bishop t2 even
though it should win here really should
and now the engine gives rookie 444 the
tech ok so this is probably not
objectively best but I just wanted some
kind of clarity Oh be 55 now is good
frame or equal equal 0 0 0 94 is winning
what didn't I do that ok this isn't a
problem i have this and latta voice good
he has to allow the Queen trade and this
is a pretty easy win so this was the
issue oh wow hmm yeah it sets indeed
that's not easy I have to play King the
two now according to the computer check
dodging a couple of kids yeah I'm
actually winning what he doesn't have to
take c3 age 6 here anything could have
happened in the blend this in blitz ok
ok so here rooks exceptions also
possible and winning ending was really a
dream come true after all those
complications ok thanks for watching